hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play drunk
minecraft if a castaway edition or
whatever we tell we're calling us I
really know I got a [ __ ] the one where
we're in this guy yes we're in the sky
on an island and we're gonna go to that
place up there I don't see a house on
there I just see a floating island I
don't think there's anything I see
special
oh there's two trees up there oh hang on
um Bob does it sure camp to be on sander
grow no that's a lie that's a dirty
dirty lie don't proliferate lies wade
okay alright so anyway we need to get up
how much cobblestone do we have 64 I'm
in a building yeah I've got sixty with
me right now I'm gonna build him we got
64 in this chest here I'm gonna we're
gonna go up to this amazing magical
island while you guys do all the menial
work that I don't want to do and then
I'm gonna film you from on high and it's
gonna look really cinematic and badass
okay okay so I use this bone to make
bone meal to grow these trees do what do
what you want do what you want Scoob
shag meet Roy Roy we're all wrong all
right that voice is just annoying now no
one low no one likes your voices Wade no
one absolutely no one well that's just
patently untrue you know what they do
like Wade they love your sellers of
Catan like can you do can we do a drunk
minecraft sellers of Catan I don't think
that can do wrong Settlers of Catan is
that a thing can that be a thing we
really feel like losing Wade oh I
totally beat you considering that I've
never played it before but since I'm so
pro at games you know I don't know if
you watched my playthrough but I beat
them all
no one's watched your playthrough Wade
but beat the melody lost each level at
least once because I'm
hahahaha
I thought mobs was much funnier than
years Wade by the Bob was I thought
you'd think that I always think that I
knew you'd think he thought that sigh I
knew you'd think I'd think that he
thought that so tell me what you think
what
really really thought tell me what you
want tell me what you really really want
really really want what you really want
tell me what you want what you want how
does it go
you wanna know what's wrong with that
tree it's blue
I kid it's a mushroom it's a giant
mushroom I saw that on the way up we're
gonna get that in a second but I'm gonna
start a farm do I have any wheat no why
not we didn't start with any seeds we
started with pumpkin seeds and melon
seeds I've got these hang on whoa
everything crashed are you guys freezing
no whoa I was totally that's I stopped
in time guys okay you okay yeah buddy
we're fine everybody okay are you all
care out there what happened did I just
have a seizure the Jeep pour beer on
your computer you know no what's it did
you stop recording
no oh [ __ ] I trampled on the melons dude
I traveled on one melon holy crap we're
almost to the same level as the other
place now we did more cobble I'm gonna
get Halle
two-thirds of the way there may be a way
there's oh there's another pick in the
in the thing in the guy West I love was
actually not another pick in there there
is this yeah I left mine in there I took
the stone one there's a wood one in
there there's four sticks two sides 11
torches 600 it's in my inventory sorry
but wait come on you should have
realized that yeah so dumb white huh so
I was totally looking in your inventory
yes you should have
all right so I'm laggy freezing
libraries see that's what happened to me
that's what happened to Mary oh it's
happened to me wait ah wait wait wait
wait wait ah hey what tell us a story of
a man named brainish oh shut up tell us
a story from your childhood
oh god those aren't good you're really
well your whole life is practically
really depressing so tell us a story
I'll make up one ya know tell us a real
story can be sad can be really sad cuz I
know that's the range of your stories
ahead and really
yep that's the story of your life unless
steal three if you're cobblestone wait
that's five
I need another pick sorry where's this
story Wade I'm thinking of which one I
should tell it's like ology I could talk
about my family splitting up or my dad
died those are really sad uh-huh yeah
yeah the saddest day of all what the
helps my skype just went to what deaf
good go back head do not disturb what
the hell my skype has been acting up I
swear it's been really really stupid
haha
I need my continued Wade was about about
your your whole family being dead
nothing was bad about it you know those
things that happens ah ah I shouldn't be
laughing okay anyway on two different
not depressing stuff Wade why you gotta
bring us down hahaha I gotta bring us
down win
yeah wait I can't believe that she Jesus
what the hell Wade see sees you just
wait this is why I need a therapist
okay so anyway uh are we almost up at
the other Island
yeah getting there I'm about to build
another cobblestone farmer so we can all
do it I'll do it together a little bit I
have connected this all the dirt you
guys suck no we planted all the dirt
around us on the bridge yeah we use it
all around the perimeter I use six
blocks on the bridge for six blocks we
don't have now shut up Wade
Bob's okay Bob's under a lot of stress
right now so don't understand that's a
hole in the ground good Bob died almost
a we have a tree oh my god
do we Oh Bob you're back here okay I'm
gonna go up I got cobblestone time
enough try to find Laura mark come here
no way screw you my hole well I've not
messed with your hole Bob whatever that
means
hey come in my hole anyway remember that
anybody everybody yes oh oh my god I
saved it Oh what did you draw I just
fell off the world but got a desert out
ha ha ha up to the stream of water and
saved my own life
ha ha ha ha
well done Bob why is there a stream Oh
No Oh Fraulein a head empty buckets all
right I know where our lava is I'm gonna
come get it it's sitting down here
hanging in midair weight loss lob oh
yeah there's a lava block down here in
the middle of nowhere I'm gonna get a
empty bucket come harvest it that
doesn't make any damn sense
yeah how'd it get there what is move it
I didn't do it
wait Bob explain yourself
what was she talking about oh crap the
waters a trap now what you talking about
Bobby it's someone opened the top of the
water so I can get back into the I am
way too far away to be bothered with any
of that you guys uh Oh No oh no Brian oh
no I am so I'm still really choppy Bob
are you alive yeah I just trapped it
honors open Bob water hell hole no dude
you're the wrong one or the other one to
the other one
and I'm coming back melon see the Savior
is coming markiplier is here I'm sure
today helped you're too late hey I'm
here to clip oh you trampled the crops
damn it man I return from the dead so
bite me Jesus we only have one melon in
one pumpkin now what the hell
all right fine I'm gonna build the rest
of the bridge with this cobblestone in
here we need a little more though we
need lots more actually and I have some
cobblestone no okay I didn't think so
no you get cobblestone what we're good
at ready Bob wait entertain us with more
voices I ask you to one thing you didn't
even do a voice god knows what first yes
please thank you very much I just want
to kill you they're not so process model
was the kills myth for horses no don't
do that
I need that that's my thing I'm gonna
stroll into love make the stairs go
somewhere else the Browns the stuff okay
wait you can stop the voices now
I'm no longer entertained by them for
school is they way that's gone no one
knows that reference anymore wait no one
knows that that one time you saying that
why do I still get tweeted that you
don't even know anything about that
no no one cares about what is it going
is it but white lady is you're going he
screamed into his phone and had Siri try
to record him and he screamed for like
20 seconds and all that it showed was is
it going I'm gonna scream in the Siri
again totally how much I hate you and
wait wait why so much good bye uh-huh
okay it's done what did series say what
[ __ ] you it's a goodbye
hahahaha you Cirie about joke ran out of
Baba I don't know why that happened Bob
you put a piece of dirt there well now I
have an empty bucket so bones and other
lava Bob why is there a lava still here
okay good Jesus Bob jeez Bob just get
out of my way okay I think I have enough
to build the rest of the bridge there's
actually iron up there thank goodness
now we're gonna use if we're gonna
survive but I'm going up here while it's
almost night time so I might die so I
place the tarsals
I got torches no met them and stuff set
them and stuff set them we're on the
road I don't know yeah on the yes just
light it okay all right fine jeez I got
it oh my god there's a super creeper up
here hey I got a bucket of lumps all
glowy and stuff oh it's coming after me
oh we gotta kill it oh yeah got it
I nailed it I killed it we need more
lava there's apparently an unending
source of lava down here
unending how's it unending I don't know
it's a bunch of lava blocks somehow lava
isn't supposed to be unending
well I'm gonna fill up all of our
buckets with lava is that sound good
okay do that I don't know even know how
many buckets we have we have at least
like four don't we Irish of it and I've
ruined at least two of them so how did
you ruin them I well I did the same
thing I did to yours twice now so yeah
you destroyed the lava yeah again no I
did that earlier okay you did I don't
remember that that was remember one I
saw oh no my love is gone oh haha
Nikes I went too high huh that's fine
whatever you're fine I'm gonna harvest
some more lava okay I'm gonna make sure
she was your thank you for appreciating
my hard work
oh my god I fell out of that oh my god
something amazing is happening over
there that I don't know so you're gonna
need to be very descriptive what's going
on to you he's bleeding from the eye
sockets he's bleeding from his anus
sockets yes that's what I said his anus
I don't think people have anus sockets
Wade anybody actually can hear good way
yeah Lizzie that ooh ah oh there's Oh
anything else going on oh very scripted
cuz we can't hear no Marcy I'm here you
oh oh oh it's a paradise up here papers
on the stairs ah ah it's so nice over
here seriously it's so nice there was
this cake and a chair and a music box
it's so nice and ironed
I just ruined a carrot but yeah that's
okay there's crops in a farm and steak
no that's actually quite good Wade you
don't need to cry no I'm just gonna stay
here this is something special this is
something that needs to be cherished
guys you should come up here it's a no
I'm not exaggerating here I think it
really is kind of cool
what that why are skeletons coming up
whoa whoa whoa
a skeleton's what the hell where do they
come from
speed skillets yeah they just start
sprinting after me what the hell sounds
like you've got two tickets to paradise
what does that even mean Wade that has
no contact right now there there are
four of us wherever you go
therefore you are we talking about Wade
if you have five and you take away two
you don't have five well I mean that's
correct but I still don't know what
you're talking about
Oh someone took the sword you suck
I took the sword cuz I was going to
fight some monsters thank you very much
now I am everything you got son
oh damn it oh you suck so bad I keep my
items because there's somebody monsters
on these stairs I fell again I kept all
my items I got everything huh give me my
items back right oh my god okay there
are creepers on the stairs - so
everyone's aware which stairs also
there's a hole in the stairs now
good job Wade never thought I'd say
those words my good looks no cuz you're
a dude wait are there any torches down
there um I have torches give it at the
chest
I have torches torch the stairs okay I
have torches hanging I'll get him just
just so that ya just burn everything
because yet spiders and stuff
is that why oh my god oh no what why we
opened the door to the other the bridge
and they were all coming over oh crap
okay the tear the stairs are properly
torched we got plenty of illumination
here shouldn't be any monsters
problematic but seriously I got iron
I have iron guys I have iron I don't
think you understand the amazingness
that I have iron we should make is there
any stuff up there oh I got most of it
besides the dirt in the giant mushroom
but you can go there just good luck
getting back because I'll go get the
dirt wait hang on it's a drop-off
there's there may not be enough material
to get up there I've got 30 with me I
can build
okay you do that I'm gonna I'm gonna
live there there's also some crops up
there are you guys run into stuff Oh
some of them really really guys really
Reaper really you took the only sword
[ __ ] so you could have punched it
and backed up is your only method for
killing creepers strangling them after
they're dead or after they're alive or
you know what I meant
don't twitch my words the sword that's
what we do there is a gigantic hole here
yeah this is was a creeper whoa why I
never mind all right you know what don't
even care I was going to join you
because we've been separated for so long
all right oh I'm a-comin okay all right
okay we're gonna work together like to
fix it
Kane's not even growing you're not even
growing I have a growth defect yeah yeah
I stopped six-foot-four by the way you
guys know that um after I froze that
cyndago people kept telling me like they
commented on the videos I didn't realize
Mark was so short like that was like a
comment all over the place and I never
understood one what why Bobo's right
here there was a skeleton you could have
backed up and let me take care of it you
knew I had the sword you were standing
there watching me get raped Marquis you
go back I never mind I would have
thought of his thing yeah okay anyway
whatever shut up wait so anyway I was
down cyndago and people commenting other
videos like wow I didn't know bark was
so short what is he like four foot nine
I'm like oh come on I mean I'm not tall
but I'm not that short am i you are kind
of short well compared to you Giants but
you're both 624 like you're both six
before I lead the way or douche Oh what
else are I was waiting for you okay
watch this this is how they professional
wow there's a lot of monsters up there
yeah I know right I don't get
these fast skeletons are weird okay
that's one down
creeper comer gloom Oh creepy combo so
I'm just gonna maintain the illusion
that I'm like I am four foot nine so
let's just keep saying that number to
everyone I mean ah you know lots of
people asked me on the street everyday
how tall you are
I know I know I know because they all
know not why did you build these stairs
in the most treacherous what possible
shut up it was the only way to save
douche bag that was sucks you do a way
does I think we can all agree oh you
guys you guys are bad at this I got hit
by a bow and arrow I got nothing to do
my dad you guys suck at this game oh
stop god damn it oh shut up wait stop
babying Oh
alright I think we need some divine
intervention here like I think we need
the astrological forces to start messing
with us if that's even possible I don't
know if they can being the big bit here
let me Adam Jesus Christ you're so oh
wait why did you get in the way I didn't
know you were in my ass I ran right in
front of you are you kidding me oh my
god wait felt nothing you deserve that
two centimeters you deserve that alright
so anyway so once we jump off into here
it turns into paradise like really
quickly get out of here you zombie
bastard all right so now I'm gonna torch
this place and see we're good Bob I'm
trying to stairs
you're trying to stairs it'd be easier
to go from the bottom up don't you think
that's true
cake I'm gonna eat the last bite of cake
Rob do you want anything okay good job
Bob you ate the last of the cake okay
yeah there's no cake left wait there's
exactly no cake left
jerks who built these stairs this is
like I built the stairs because it's an
efficient diagonal design yeah yeah
efficient that's the word I would be use
you've got a bunch of arrows in your
face
Wade yeah wonder why makes you
marginally look a little better but not
much get it cuz you're so ugly I get to
your vision
ah who makes stupid stairs now Wade
doctor I lagana octagon Alaska
dr. okoda bush whoa I haven't seen that
forever if anyone out there doesn't know
what we're talking about we're talking
about the laser collection Bob now this
is stupid design how in the world I'm
fixing you how in the world are you
supposed to get on here in the field was
the most efficient use of the stone that
I had I don't think it was because it's
the minimum number of blocks to make a
stairway that goes up that high
okay oh this isn't a mushroom this is an
umbrella oh I get it cuz this is like a
little one cow oh good no oh and
Guardium Livio strong no one else no one
else just me okay where else and I'm
gonna be single
wait why you gotta be such an a-hole why
can't you just get up here in our new
paradise why why cuz [ __ ] stairs kill
me
look retards dick alright you know what
fine I'll fix the stairs
there's no accesing Aires Wade it was
born that way baby cuz he made y'all so
ass Lady gaga
I don't even think she would think that
was even close to her rendition so
probably it's probably just fine just
saying I think she is flattered that I
sound just like her wow you made these
less safe congratulation how what did I
do
I'm trying to fix them they're better
now just shut up you want to screw you
Wade you should see the stairway are you
you can't miss hook down you're lucky I
ran out of pickaxe right then in there
Oh what were you gonna do we're gonna do
you're gonna hit me I knew it
I never gotta find me gonna hit you ha
ha ha was that how Archer laughs ha see
Archer is one of those shows that I do
not like so I wouldn't know anything
about that you don't like I like it
remember you tried to get me to like
Archer and I didn't like it it's a good
show you like it I did not care for it
oh you're just being obtuse you know
what is good show though I'm just a cute
shut up Wade whose line is it anyway is
returning in July which is right around
the corner I'm so excited
if anyone out there doesn't watch whose
line when it comes out I'm gonna come to
your house and I'm gonna find you and
strangle you in your sleep that's that's
all I can say about that
that's good well there's some
encouragement
I guess well I guess some people do it
just so that I can come over to their
house
I guess people like to be strangled
London Abbott Eiffel
we um complete challenges because we've
done a bunch of these if not the stuff
in your inventory and hit like slash oh
yes I see space see then the challenge
name or something like that / CC my
playmate and stuff + CC my playmate you
see my play may come and play with me is
that some porn site wade yeah that's a
porn site little children that jump rope
to it much porn will they jump hahaha I
don't know what that is so it might
might be something more in jump ropes
something in your giant porn collection
wade yeah my porn collection is so bird
yeah it's so weird
Oh giant porn collection this whole
thing on a stick you thought was a
mushroom from a distance yeah you know
was giant mushrooms I guess from a
distance I see see see
do you see Wade do you see how stupid
you are and how smart I am
I've never seen how smart you are you
will see someday you will know the true
genius of my mind who's the true genius
of your mind
no no Molly Oh Molly's the true genius
over my yeah see the secret's out tell
him Molly tell me Molly
huh tell Molly she has no idea top
blowing I'll try to do some more free
see do you see wait there's Molly right
there cuz that's it said what she sounds
like is like that a mouse on a helium
balloon so Molly Molly how do you like
being with Wayde
he's kind of boring here's your
impression ball do tell
oh she hears you surprised me we talked
about Bob this is Molly we're talking
this is small younger girl cuz I'm sure
that the Bob's webcam was not at all
I'll let it all edit it I'll edit it out
yeah all I did it
everyone's gonna believe that's really
Molly because it is it is everyone
that's Molly so much this is Molly for
sure mom Holly Molly do you regret
moving in with way do you do know I get
free food so it's a pretty good deal I
can understand that that's respectable
okay Bobby you know what's my opinion
with Wade yeah what's it like being near
Wade and having to deal with him every
day is that is that is that a man that's
not Molly
I got a sucker don't you I did it all
edit it huh I'll edit it out all get it
all in post oh oh wait
Bob do zombies parrot Molly go ha ha ha
ha come on do it go I'll be pilot it's
not it's not ready yet
okay all right wait so could you go
cookie oh wait wait wait wait it does
like you're roasting a chicken alive so
make me laugh I got hair shut up shop
everybody out there shut up
I may be I sound like I'm 80 is that no
hi matey okay
I'm 80 yes I'm 80 okay that was good
that was good okay no yes good that's
that's no way do your zombie pirate
Molly ha ha ha ha that's not gonna
happen
Marsh
I guess we don't know what waits Molly
I'm clearing my throat I'm not done it
yet okay I thought that was your thing
are we clear my throat oh yeah we'd be
so awesome yeah the word zombie where's
the zombie that's his pirate
ah a lot I need weights brains are got a
parrot on me shoulder that's also dead
that's my that's my zombie pirate my
house it spreads all your soldiers badly
it's a pie cuz it's a pirate got a
parrot on your shoulder in dead 2 cuz
it's a zombie get it get it I get it
again is an undead parrot or yes no
she's a skeleton it's too dark
squawk Mali the parents name is Polly
and it's Molly Polly so Molly Polly
squally is the parrot on your salat your
salat shut up Wade that didn't work at
all those toys stupid no one appreciates
your jokes they're a dog don't you'll
lose ah tree Oh tree hi okay hang on
wait no I got bonemeal hang on let me
grow those other trees before you kill
me what are you guys doing also is molly
angry yet just interested wait hang on
this this isn't working the bone meal
didn't work always living the bone meals
didn't work angry people here
livid people people who want to wring my
neck over here let's stay orderly people
we live with those who want to wring my
neck
god I love Brian Regan he needs to come
out with a new CD he really does I saw
him live and he had new stuff in it so
well you know what's awesome the other
like not the other day like a couple
months ago I had to go to a butterfly
pavilion uh and and I walked in there
and this woman was in there and was like
welcome to the butterfly pavilion if you
have any questions feel free to ask me
okay huh and I looked her dead in the
eye and I was just like ha oh okay we
got like 30 seconds left by the by does
this one like to eat she didn't get it
needless to say yeah it's okay I got it
all here I'll answer all your butterfly
questions oh really when you have a long
flight
okay Sonia we've got 30 seconds left
this mysterious item fell in my
inventory that says what's the time and
apparently we're actually out of time
mysterious entity yeah why why does thou
need task time to tell or not to tell
that is the question
a tree well I guess we're done so I
guess not paradise there's a cherry
we've added to paradise forget who's the
winner who who's the winner that's what
we need to decide who won this adventure
I'm pretty sure it's me why you why are
you gonna win I'm the only one who
hasn't been a total dick the whole time
ha ha ha what I do is true oh oh really
oh really really
I just mean Bob wins good reasons okay
goody
oh yeah Abel this whole games a sham
you're a [ __ ] I don't anything since
freakin Towers of iron oh my god what's
happening okay so what does that mean
well yeah you did no I don't think yeah
I think it's been a while since Bob
actually want anything so what's what's
going on can we end it
is that it all right guys everybody so
bob has a Twitter wait as a kept Bob
show ha hey stormy oh oh all right okay
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos it
I've done or we've done mostly I've done
and as always we will see you on YouTube
jerks in the next video call you call
them jerks you really call by audience
just one or two jerks I said Bob any
winner
I said you out of you two I said these
things anyway so say that more
profession I don't think you're jerks
hahahahahaha my camera holy crap hahaha
that was a great way to impression oh
that is just drool okay so anyway thank
you all so much for watching and we will
see you in the next video bye
Oh
just trying to have a nice calm relaxing
I did not
on me
there's a good
like
but always good
own
is kind of very